today's one minute Monday is do one
thing if you're starting up in any new
project you're going to be quickly
overwhelmed by the number of options
there's so many things that you have to
do so many ways to go that you don't end
up doing anything
pick one thing focus on that and get it
done and you'll realize that over the
weeks you're actually getting stuff done
this came as a result of a coaching call
I had with my media coach who gives me
advice on how to make my youtube videos
better radio shows better and last week
she gave me 30 different options of
things that I need to work on and
they're all great I need to work on them
but because it was so overwhelming in
the past week I did nothing I didn't
touch any of them this is too much
so I told her today on the call give me
one thing
give me one assignment I trust your
judgment give me one thing I need to
work on and I'll do it I'll get it done
and she said okay do a one-minute Monday
that's your project this week this is my
one-minute monday if you have anything
big and it's scary and overwhelming and
preventing you from moving forward I'm
taking action pick one thing to do this
week follow through on it and do one
more next week and one more next week
until you get them all done believe you
guys like this new format let me know
give it a thumbs up leave a comment I'll
see you soon